[Music]
what do you make of all this Thomas
Marco madness well it is madness there
is so much confusion there have been so
many mixed messages I mean frankly this
is not how we usually do royal weddings
et's Kevin Frazier getting insight into
how the royal family is handling the
Tomas Marco paparazzi scandal and
fallout from royal watcher Katie Nichol
as you can see the royal standard is
flying outside Buckingham Palace which
means her Majesty the Queen is in I'm
sure no one wants to upset the Queen by
mentioning the whole Thomas Markel
debate and who knows whether she's been
updated with the latest from TMZ which
is that Thomas Markel is now saying he
does want to be there to make that
historic walk down the aisle with his
daughter will they accept this now and
say okay come on Thomas come on down
well I can tell you I spoke with the
palace earlier on today apparently no
changes were made to the order of
service I was told that Megan had been
in 11th our talks with her father they
had quite a few conversations late into
the night last night with Megan really
pleading with her dad telling him that
this didn't matter they could get over
this but she really wanted him to be
there for her special day and I guess
the please daddy it worked so it would
break her heart if he doesn't show up I
was told by sources close to Megan last
night that she was utterly heartbroken
that she couldn't believe that this was
happening just days before her wedding
we will hope for some sort of an
announcement from Kensington Palace I
would imagine towards the end of the
week confirming whether or not Thomas
Markel is going to be a part of the
ceremony if Thomas Markel doesn't come
over to the UK then we're in slightly
uncharted territory I'm wondering if
perhaps someone from the royal family
might step in and do the ultimate in
chivalry and take Thomas Marshalls place
and really who better to do that than
Prince Charles he doesn't have a formal
role at the wedding as such it can't
really be William because William was
going to be at the top of the church
keeping Harry's nerves in check so you
may just find that the
subwhales may use this as an opportunity
to step in and and escort Megan down the
aisle he's in a perfectly placed
position to do so and if anyone can
stack all her nerves I would have
thought it would be Charles
[Music]
[Applause]